hi I'm Michael wascom um I'm a ml
engineer at flat iron Health uh which is
a company in New York City that uses
technology to accelerate cancer research
and improve Cancer Care um but I'm here
today to talk about Seaborn uh a python
library that I'm the Creator and
maintainer
of uh so if you're not familiar uh
Seaborn is a python data visualization
Library that's based on the map plot lib
framework um so map plot lib very
general library but relatively low-level
uh Seaborn offers a higher level
interface that is specifically geared
towards creating statistical
Graphics uh so this talk is going to be
about what I've learned over the past
decade or so of Seaborn development um
and how that's informed the current and
future directions of the
library Seaborn started out with with
pretty humble Ambitions it was
essentially a a toolbox or an extension
to map plot lib that offered a few
plotting functions uh with statistical
capabilities doing things like fitting a
kernel density estimate to a histogram
or a linear regression line to a scatter
plot and these functions behaved a lot
like the rest of map plot lib they you
know primarily operated on numpy arrays
because that was the you know main data
structure at the
time uh but this was around when p was
starting to get popular and bringing the
idea of a you know labeled columnar data
structure to
Python and so some of the early Seaborn
functions borrowed you know built on
that and borrowed some ideas from the r
Community about tidy data um using data
frames uh at first really to make you
know faceted or paired small multiple
plots with features like conditional
color mapping where the color mapping
was really thought of as a you know
fating operation on the third dimension
of the
plot and as Seaborn developed I was
primarily concerned with filling gaps in
matplot lib's feature set especially
features that were important for
emerging data science applications uh so
map plot lib's roots are in the physical
sciences and it hasn't always served
analytics and machine learning use cases
um as well as it could so for instance
you know one of the first major
distinguishing features of Seaborn was
its uh for for categorical data and kind
of plots that are optimized for
categorical
data and eventually you know this landed
us in a kind of odd situation where
Seaborn had support for some fairly
complex Graphics things like regression
or violin plots uh but not simple ones
uh like you know just basic line or
Scatter Plots and remember the initial
intention or thought was add on to what
Matt plot lib doesn't have and Matt plot
lib you know already had those
things but it didn't have this you know
tidy API API where you could just pass
in a data frame and name some columns
and have those automatically mapped to
components of the plot so uh almost I
think five years or so after the first
release of Seaborn it it kind of finally
gained such Basics as as a line plot and
a scatter plot function um but not just
in their simplest forms uh in forms that
had support for mapping now up to three
additional Dimensions uh based on the
columns in a data frame including you
know color and size and the style of the
elements in the
plot and so seaborn's objective remained
you know help people make plots faster
so that they can understand their data
better um but it's focus and you know
how it did that shifted from do their
statistics for them to you know give
them an intuitive interface that lets
them you know rapidly inter uh rapidly
iterate and think about their data not
the mechanics of specifying a graph
and so you know that prompted me to
revisit even some of the oldest
functions in the library and to try to
impose some API consistency um onto
these tools that had you know grown
rather organically and at the start
without much intentional thought about
API
design so despite this somewhat
halfhazard and organic development the
result the kind of status quo is a
library that can be used to produce a
relatively wide range of informative
statistical graphics with a reasonably
coherent
API and the API model you know that the
API encourages encourages a mental model
where you might say I want to make a
line plot and then there's a function
called line plot that you can do to do
that uh or there's a function called bar
plot and you can probably guess what
that
does and so one objective of caborn is
that each of these functions should be
able to produce a usable plot with a
bare minimum set of arguments really
just enough to specify the
data they make some inferences about
what you want based on the data types uh
and they try to use sensible defaults
and they produce complete Graphics they
add labels and legends so you can very
quickly get from an idea or a question
you have to a plot that you could at
least you know show to one of your
colleagues and they'd understand what it
is but customization is important uh
good customization requires rapid
iteration um and so each function
exposes a number of additional
parameters that afford varying kinds of
control so these range from specifying
the mappings between your data set the
visual properties in the plot setting
hyperparameters of whatever statistical
operations that function is going to
perform and tweaking the plot's final
appearance now it's not quite true that
you can customize everything just
through the parameters of the caborn
functions recall that it started with
the idea of you know like map plot lid
but with some statistics uh and so the
functions Were Meant to fit into the
standard map plot lib workflow um which
means that you know while Seaborn will
add default labels to the plot if you
want to customize them You' use M po
Libs API for
that still you can get most of the way
there by interacting uh just with the
caborn API and that's helped you know a
lot of people make a lot of useful
plots uh but I've also come to
appreciate you know over the years some
of the limitations that this design
imposes
so one obvious consequence is that each
of these parameters has a each of these
functions has a lot of
parameters and anyone functions
parameters do a lot of different kinds
of
things so well on the one hand you know
it's straightforward to explain how
Seaborn Works you're just specifying
parameters you find a function that you
think is going to do what you want you
look at its list of parameters to see
what options it has but with so many
parameters and just in one you know
linear list uh it can be hard to know
you know what bits and pieces you're
going to need to solve any specific
problem and then because Seaborn is a
higher level interface to map plot lib
some of the parameters that you need to
set might actually be map plot Li
parameters and even just within Seaborn
some functions are at a higher level
than others and so the API relies
heavily on keyword argument passing
which means to understand what
parameters a function takes you might
need to walk through several different
pages of documentation across multiple
project
websites in the you know organic
development of the library has led to uh
an expanding scope over time has has led
to some other opportunities for for
friction or confusion so take you know
as a case study the strip plot and the
scatter plot
functions these are both fundamentally
Scatter Plots or what they create are
fundamentally Scatter Plots um but as I
mentioned earlier the function called
strip plot actually came first uh
because it's a scatter plot that's
optimized for categorical data it's
meant as an alternative or a complement
to a box or violin plot so it has
capabilities like dodging and jittering
uh that make sense in that
context and then the scatter plot
function came later uh producing plots
that are in one sense more basic uh but
on the other hand and have more options
for mapping properties Based on data
they allow you to control the size of
the dots and the shape of the markers
whereas strip plot only controls the
color so you know you might find
yourself starting to make a plot using
one of these functions realizing that I
can't do everything you want switching
to one of the other functions and then
realizing you've lost some of the
features that you were relying
on now you can always add features um
but the design makes this hard too uh
and paradoxically it can feel hardest to
add small features small little nice to
haves that just add a little polish or
you know satisfy a few um you know less
common use
cases so as an example take the concept
of adding a gap or a little spacing
between the boxes in a box plot when you
dodge them it's a totally reasonable
thing you know I I I like the way this
looks um but implementing it would mean
adding a parameter uh to uh to box plot
to control you know whether there's a
gap how big the Gap is um and so that
already long list of parameters is going
to grow a little bit and that's going to
impose an ongoing cost to usability
everyone in the future who comes and
looks at the list of parameters is going
to have one more that they need to sift
through to understand what they you know
what they can
do and here's the thing this this
despite the way it's articulated on
GitHub here this isn't really just a
request about the boxplot function you
know adding this would also uh mean
changing the bar plot function and the
violin plot function um all the other
ones that all the other functions that
you know have some sort of dodging
operation um you either have to change
all of them or you have to add like more
inconsistency or accept more
inconsistency in the library and so
beyond uh implementing that operation in
the code itself you know each function
also has tests and documentation that
would need to be updated so it just
increases the costs of adding even small
things
when seaborn's functions don't support a
feature you know one option is to drop
down to the underlying map plot lib
layer accomplish what you want there map
plot lib is still a python Library lots
of people know how to use it um and this
was part of the original design right
curn was just adding some things that
you couldn't do in map plot lib so if
there was something it couldn't do you
know no harm you just carry on as if
Seaborn wasn't there uh but as Seaborn
has developed more capabilities and its
own you know style of API the gap
between the two libraries has grown um
and so it's no longer a valid assumption
and it's also no longer a valid
assumption that any Seaborn user is also
comfortable using malot lib you know
lots of places have started teaching
data science using Seaborn because it's
a little easier a little bit you know
faster to get started out of the
box so after nearly a decade I you know
decided to take a step back and think if
I were designing this library from
scratch and had from the start a focus
on a you know flexible but consistent
interface that was easy to use and
didn't constrain what you could do you
know what would that look
like so the result is what I'm calling
the objects interface or Seaborn doobs
uh it's a totally new approach basically
a groundup rewrite uh that takes
inspiration both from things that worked
well in classic Seaborn um and from
libraries that are more explicitly based
on the formal grammar of Graphics uh
like yes ggplot um also Vega parts of D3
um you know other libraries that are out
there that have built on some of these
ideas so while people have sometimes
referred to Classic Seaborn as you know
ggplot in Python I've always thought
that's that's wrong um or at least
overselling it you know Seaborn has
certainly taken ideas and inspiration
from ggplot since the beginning but it's
also always had a narrower Ambitions
it's not intended to be a you know fully
uh flexible system for producing
Graphics the objects interface is much
more explicit based on the you know
underlying formalism and also has
somewhat broader Ambitions to be more
General um it's still not ggplot in
Python though it's not going to be you
know a direct Port of uh the syntax that
you might be used to if you're a ggplot
user um it should feel familiar I hope
you know I I think the learning curve
should be pretty rapid um but it's uh
you know it's a different Library I
always say that you know if if what you
want is just to take your ggpa code and
have it run in Python um you should
check out the plot N9 library and uh
today you're in luck because you just
have to wait a few minutes and you'll
hear about that um but for the time
being uh let me walk you through how I
approach this in
caborn so everything in the objects
interface is built around an object
called plot uh plot has a number of
methods and you call these methods to
specify how various aspects of the graph
should appear so that includes data
specification adding layers
parameterizing the scales customizing
the decorations and the theme of the
plot every time you call one of its
methods you're gradually adding on to
the
spec and it's called the objects
interface because Beyond plot uh there's
a number of other objects that you pass
to plot's methods to define the
graph so there's four basic types of
objects Mark stat move and
scale a mark is a visual element like a
DOT or a line a stat defines a
statistical operation
a move implements a positional
adjustment and a scale maps from data to
visual
properties let's see these in
action so you call the plot Constructor
with a data source and some assignments
from variables in the data set to roles
in the plot now this looks a lot like a
function call in the classic interface
uh but if we compile this spec uh we
would see just an empty graph with some
labels on the axes you won't actually
get a data visualization until we add
layers to the
plot and you do that hopefully
intuitively with a method called plot.
add so every layer is defined by at
least a mark object here I'm using a a
dart a dot mark so it's producing a
scatter plot uh and you'll notice that
when I Define the layer I'm setting the
point size of the dot to a specific
value and then also associating the
marker uh the dot marker with another
column from the data frame
so there's three ways to Define visual
properties here there's properties that
are in the plot Constructor that are
mapped in all layers there's properties
defined in the mark Constructor that are
set directly to the value you give
independent of any of the data and then
properties defined in the call to plot.
add which are mapped uh but in a layer
specific
way for this plot there's no real
difference between whether you specify
color in the plot Constructor
or when you're calling add but if we
added another layer um such as a line
representing a regression fit um you'd
see that only the colors of the line are
mapped so as in classic Seaborn the
default scales are chosen for each
mapping variable based on uh the data
types and you know other inferences
about the plot spec um but there's a
method called plot. scale that allows
you to explicitly override and Supply
the the mapping you want to use so for
example here I'm choosing slightly more
intuitive mapping from true false to a
circle and an
X for full customization you can pass an
instance of a scale object like a
nominal scale or a continuous scale um
there's also a number of short hands
like just passing a dictionary or a list
that imply a specific scale
type the notion of small multiple plots
remains very important to seor any plot
can be distributed across a grid of uh
subplots by calling plot. facet and
supplying one or two additional columns
from your data frame that Define the
rows and the columns in the facet
grid and there's also a method called
plot. pair which U also produces
subplots that look a lot like a a facet
plot um but much like the classic
Seaborn pair grid class or pair plot
function um here we're taking multiple
columns from the initial data frame and
assigning them to the uh different
subplot X or Y AES so this is like
fating and you could basically reshape
your data and also accomplish this
through a facet operation but sometimes
it's more convenient to skip the
reshaping
step so unlike in the classic caborn
interface you use the same term to
either map a property Based on data or
set it directly what matters is where
you do it um and you can map a much
wider range of visual properties so that
includes multiple color attributes the
alpha or the opacity of the mark and
whether the Mark is
filled uh where appropriate you can
control style properties like the marker
shape or the dash pattern that's used
for a line or the edge of a patch
there's a number of size based
properties like the point size of a dot
mark the width of the lines or edges of
a patch um and The Strokes uh that
define linear
markers if you have a text Mark in your
plot you can also control the font size
alignment and offset from The Anchor
Point usually you'd set these directly
but it's possible to map them to There's
no distinction between mappable and
unmappable
parameters so I think the ergonomics
here are a lot better there's no more
keyword redirection across multiple
functions if you're in a notebook or an
IDE all the property is supported by
plot or by a specific marker just going
to tab complete out the documentation is
going to be right
there and if you think back the
discussion about you know adding a gap
parameter to all the functions that
support dodging um you know that's no
longer relevant here there's just a
single object it's called Dodge you add
it to any plot spec and the marks in
that layer will get dodged um and that's
the you know the Gap parameter can just
be defined there there's only three
parameters in this class it's very easy
to understand what it can do and then it
composes with any
Mark so we're not in the situation with
strip plot and scatter plot where you
have to choose between between
categorical adjustments and mapping
additional
properties object interface lets you
combine all of these operations into one
plot
spec now with that said this particular
example is maybe a little over stuffed
with information uh you know the classic
interface is opinionated uh which is a
nice way of saying it limits what you
can do um and so usually that takes you
towards doing things that make sense
prevents but sometimes it prevents you
from doing things that that make sense
in a specific
context so the object interface will
make you make plots that you know maybe
don't make so much sense uh and that's
because there will be some data sets
some contexts where you know this
specific set of operations when you
throw them all together does produce an
informative graph and so you know when I
was developing uh the the new interface
you know one objective I had in mind was
you know make it possible to produce
graphs that really don't make any sense
uh so that you avoid preventing people
from making plots that do right
and I think uh I you know I I I call
this successful um you know so do you
want a jittered bark plot with unfilled
bars where the edge width represents an
ordinal
variable um I kind of hope you
don't uh but if you did you could make
it with with Seaborn
objects um okay so final slide you know
what's the status of this work um it's
released but in a kind of experimental
State few things that are you know kind
of being sorted out but it's usable I
use it every day if you use the classic
interface and you like it and this has
you concerned that it's going away it's
not it's not being deprecated I'm going
to continue to support it and with that
thank
you thank
you I'm going to ask you one really
quick question sure in which language is
the backend code for Seaborn doobs
written it's all python it's all still
talking to M plot lib I have some
experiments uh where you can actually
compile it down to JavaScript we'll see
what comes of those um but yeah at the
moment it's still on python thank you
very much let's thank our speaker
[Applause]
again